Narrator: This video will show active learning
using worksheets in a large interactive physics
class.
It will discuss why and how to use worksheets
in lecture.
The class is one section of an algebra-based
introductory course that has typically 750
students enrolled in three sections.
When entering the lecture hall, the students
pick up a worksheet that contains most of
the activities for the lecture.
In this example, the worksheet is designed
to support an understanding of electric circuits.
The class starts with a relatively brief introduction.
The students are reminded of what has been
discussed so far and some context for the
class is provided.
Instructor: You remember this example from
last class with the two identical bulbs and
there was a switch across one of the light
bulbs, across bulb B
Narrator: The introduction ends with a motivation
for the first worksheet task and then students
are directed to start working on the first
worksheet problem
Instructor: Use the definition of power
and our circuit rules to predict what happens
when this switch
Narrator: Students are typically given 7-8
minutes to work, during which they are encouraged
to discuss solution strategies with their
peers.
Instructor: In my approach, the worksheets
are actually the second exposure of the students
to the new material.
The first exposure to new content happens
in the first pre-class reading assignment.
I tell my students that I expect them only
to know the basic definitions and perhaps
to understand the basic concepts, without
really expecting them to know everything in
depth at this point.
Typical worksheets contain conceptual questions
they contain relatively difficult problem
questions that where the students have to
use some important procedural knowledge such
as free-body diagrams, or graphs, or circuit
diagrams - thigs like that.
In contrast to worked problems where I just
go through the solution, the worksheet activities
give the students time to work on the problems
in class at their own pace.
Lecture TA and I visit with student groups,
we will look at their worksheets and see where
students get stuck, we will ask them where
they have difficulties if for instance,
several student groups have the same difficulties,
we can interrupt the activity and give hints
to the entire class.
Narrator: Having a teaching assistant is
valuable in such a large class.
The lecture TA answers student questions during
worksheet activities and after class.
He/She can alert the instructor to technical
problems, such as when the writing is too
small or the microphone not loud enough.
He/She can carry a microphone and repeat student
questions the instructor missed, or let the
instructor know when a solution is not clear
and needs more explanation.
The lecture TA can also give important feedback
after class and tell the instructor which
activity motivated the students and which
things are now clear or still unclear to the
students.
Instructor: I give the students roughly
7-8 minutes, based on experience, for a worksheet
problem, and it turns out that in that time,
roughly two-thirds of the students will have
finished the activity.
I often use clicker questions to help me with
the timing.
So, for instance, I ask students to answer
a follow-up clicker question, and from the
numbers the clicker shows me, I can tell how
many students have answered the question.
So I aim for roughly two-thirds of the class
to finish.
Narrator: Worksheet tasks should be difficult
enough to encourage peer discussions.
There is little value in having worksheet
problems that the students can quickly solve
on their own.
Instructor: Because not all students are
able to finish, there is of course the concern
that the weaker students become disengaged.
However, I often tell my students that they
are not expected to finish a solution that
it is important just to think very hard about
how to approach a problem and that way they
have thought about a problem enough so that
when I show the solution, they can compare
their approach to mine.
So, even if they don't finish, they get a
lot out of the worksheet activities.
Narrator: Asking a closely related clicker
question is a good way to initiate the follow-up
and bring the attention back to the instructor.
Instructor: ...or is A and B smaller than
C and D, perhaps take another minute and
discuss this with your neighbors that disagree
with your answer and see if you can convince
your neighbors.
Narrator: The clicker question and peer
discussion usually takes 3-5 minutes.
A detailed solution with discussion follows.
That can take up to 10 minutes.
So, a complete worksheet activity with follow-up
can take anywhere between 10 and 30 minutes
depending on complexity and difficulty.
In the 80-minute physics class, 4 worksheet
problems are discussed on average.
Instructor: [...] I2 is equal to I3 and
so are these greater or smaller than I1?
Instructor: The follow-up is an essential
part of a worksheet activity.
The students had spent some time thinking
hard about a solution and they want to know
now if their way, their approach, is the right
one.
So in order for them to be able to follow
my solution and to compare their thoughts,
I need to go over the solution in detailed
steps, and I need to take my time with it.
So I usually write on a document camera when
I do this, and when I explain rather than
showing the solution just on a powerpoint
slide.
I use powerpoint only for introductions and
summaries
Instructor (to class): right?
So the last steps are I can do it with you
here so you know that, let's say you get
Instructor: I don't grade my worksheets, some
instructors do, but in any case it is very
important that students get to keep their
worksheets.
The students use them as important student
tools because the worksheets contain the most
important activities for each lecture.
Narrator: Worksheets are a great way to
increase student learning in lecture.
They allow students to work at their own pace
and allow the instructor to monitor students'
progress and provide immediate feedback and
help.
Worksheets are not difficult to design and
are much appreciated by students.
[Instrumental music]